It's Michelle chemistry PhD cosmetic
chemist and owner of purple hair
today I'm going to be talking about
10 Hair hacks that changed my routine
I'm pretty lazy with my hair care I'm really
bad at sticking to routines so these won't be
high effort hacks they're things that you
can do quite easily they range from cheap
to expensive so hopefully there's something
in here that makes a big difference for you
don't forget to like and
subscribe let's get into it
crocodile clips I don't know why it took me
30 years to discover these they're called
crocodile or jointed clips and they have
this cool mechanism that expands to grab
a big chunk of hair or whatever else
you need to grab I don't know your life
I have a lot of heavy hair so I've just had
decades of weak little clips struggling to
hold onto my hair and maybe I just didn't
love myself enough to look for a solution
but one of these will just clamp onto
more than half my hair with no dramas
these cost less than a dollar
or two depending on how fancy
you go I use them for everything hair
related apart from clipping my fringe
I use them in the shower on wet and on
dry hair for treatments for dyeing my
hair clipping up my hair when it's really hot and
I don't have to leave the house so
no one has to see my great style
I used one for clipping a towel
around my partner's shoulders when
I did his quarantine haircuts I've even used them
for clipping my clothes back during
videos and clipping back curtains
I would recommend getting rubberized ones
that aren't too smooth because they grip hair
a bit better and they're also easier to hold
onto when they're wet I would also recommend
getting some with some sort of texture on the
finger grip so they don't slip out and launch
across the bathroom when your hands are
covered in conditioner learn from my fail
my hair used to snap teeth off claw
clips all the time this is a highly
recommended quality of life upgrade
treat yourself to a one dollar clip
cornstarch as dry shampoo I know a lot of people
love how convenient dry shampoo is but I found
that the sprays can make my scalp feel really
irritated and a lot of the scents are just a a
bit too heavy for me but I do have a fringe and
oily skin which means it gets gross and greasy
and I just start looking like I never grew out
of my Nine Inch Nails phase which is kind of true
I did use a dry shampoo that was like a shaker
once and it turns out the main ingredient was
starch I couldn't actually find it again and
then one time I was putting on my translucent
powder which is starch based and I thought what
if I just dusted it on my fringe and it worked
the cheaper version is just using cornstarch
from the grocery store with a fluffy brush if
your hair is dark then it can look a little bit
grey but once you brush it and like pat it down
a bit it goes away maybe try it out first on a
day when it's not right before an important event
some people also use it at night I actually
do this a lot of the time before filming like
today when I haven't planned my schedule
well enough to have a nice clean fringe
I guess a sub tip here is don't
use dry shampoo too much and stop
if you get any sores or breakouts dry
shampoo doesn't entirely replace actual
shampoo and too much gunk and build up
on your scalp just isn't very good for it
I think this is actually the reason some
people say particular products
are making their hair fall out
on that note try shampooing only your
scalp and only condition below your ears
this is a tip that I think most people already
know but if you don't this has been completely
life-changing for me the idea is basically
the hair near your scalp doesn't really need
conditioner it already gets a lot of oil from
your scalp which is actually why it needs to be
shampooed it's also less damaged because it just
hasn't been around for as long it's not old and
bitter yet so it's still pretty smooth plus most
modern shampoos have small amounts of conditioning
ingredients in them like polyquaterniums these
leave a very light protective coating on your
hair that can smooth it out protect it
against more damage also reduce static
so unless your shampoo is making your
hair very squeaky it's probably got
some conditioning that should be enough
for most people's roots so conditioner
near your scalp might not really
be adding much to your whole hair
experience but it can cause build up
on your scalp and make it irritated
now with the lengths they're far away from
your scalp so they don't get much oil the
main reason your hair gets dirty is because
of all this oil and all the dust and dirt that
sticks to it like a really gross cult I'm really
sorry I am not having a good analogy day today
so it might not actually need to be cleansed
with shampoo and this obviously doesn't apply
for shampoos with other functions like purple
shampoo so for most people directly shampooing
the lengths just dries them out and it can
make them more damaged without that much payoff
with cleaning the shampoo that trickles down as
you rinse can be enough plus hair conditioner
actually has cationic surfactants that can do
a bit of cleaning you might still need more
shampoo if you use a lot of styling products
and you might need more conditioner if your
hair is a bit rougher at the roots but for
a lot of people I think this is worth trying
my scalp used to get so much buildup
and irritation before I stopped putting
conditioner on it plus you end up using
less products so it costs you negative money
reverse conditioning if you need even deeper
conditioning you might want
to try reverse conditioning
this is where you put conditioner on the
lengths of your hair before your shampoo
and then shampoo focusing on your scalp
then you rinse everything out and add a
little bit more conditioner
if you feel like you need it
the idea is that the conditioner will
protect your hair from the shampoo so
it's like a more intense version of
the half shampoo half conditioner tip
microfiber towel they're towels that have very
small fibers so they have a large surface area
and that means that they can suck the water out
of your hair much faster than a regular towel
my favorite towels for this are the aquis
towels I've been using these same towels
for about six years ever since they sent me a
bunch for a sponsored post full disclosure but
I still use the same ones because they still
work really well and I haven't tried that many
other options I did try some cheaper ones that
I got at hair expo but they just didn't work as
well and they had that thing where they sort of
clung to your fingers and just felt really icky
Vanessa of goals to get glowing tested a bunch
and she found some cheaper options that work
great she reviewed a bunch of turbans which
are a really handy all-in-one option but I
actually prefer the regular towels because
I like being able to control how the ends
get twisted because my bleached ends are
really fragile so I put the towel around
my hair I squeeze it a bit to soak up the
water and then I wrap the towel around my
head and keep the whole thing in place
using you guessed it a crocodile clip
these are also a lot lighter than a traditional
towel so I don't get a crick in my neck when
I move my head around and it doesn't
lurch off my head and rip my hair out
nape undercut this has made such a
huge difference for me like I said I
have a lot of hair so one day I just
decided to cut off about a third of
it it's not really noticeable when I have
my hair out or in a low ponytail and most
people don't actually realize I have
one but it has made a huge difference
it is so much faster to dry my hair when my hair
has wet my head is a lot less heavy I also used
to get a whole bunch of knots when the strands
coming from like the base of my neck would rub
against my back so all of that's gone and
it is a lot cooler during summer also I had
so much hair that when I left it out without
styling it I looked a bit like grug and just
violently hacking off a whole bunch underneath
actually gives it a more manageable shape
my biggest worry about this used to be that I
would need someone to help me shave it all the
time but I found these clippers that are actually
really quite easy to use by feel it's really hard
to cut yourself on these so I can mostly keep
it shaved just by feeling where to shave and
I can almost always do it without accidentally
cutting off a whole bunch of long expensive hair
every time I accidentally cut some off I
think about how much it cost to bleach it
it's something like one cent per hair it's
not super neat around the edges because I
do try not to get any of that long hair so I
sometimes get someone to help me neaten it up
but I don't really wear my hair up a lot so
all of that shame is hiding up near the top
hair dryer with features that you want
I'm really sorry I hate hacks that I
just like buy this expensive thing but this made a
really big difference for me getting a
hairdryer that had the features I wanted
there are a lot of hair dryers out there and
my wants probably aren't the same as yours
so if you spend a lot of time drying your hair
I really encourage you to do your research and
don't just buy a hair dryer that someone else
recommends unless it does match your wants too
I've tried a lot of expensive hairdryers but this
Panasonic one just kind of blew my mind I did do
a sponsorship with them for this hairdryer
but this video is not sponsored and I have
no obligation to mention it but I am because
it did really change my mind about hair dryers
so the things I really like about this the
nozzle is designed to create an airflow that
separates your hair out so it dries faster
so you don't have to be like constantly
spreading your hair out with your fingers
I mean I still do it when I dry my hair but
I have to do it less which sounds like it
doesn't make a big difference but it does
it has a scalp function which is a setting
that goes pretty much as hot as you can get
it without burning your scalp I'm sure
it's too hot for some people but it is
pretty much perfect for me and so I can
zone out without burning my scalp or my
fingers it feels really light it's really
well balanced so there's no wrist pain I
highly recommend doing this with any
hairdryers that you might want to buy
I'm not quite extra enough to pack this
with me on holidays but every time I'm
using a hotel hair dryer and my hair is
going everywhere and slapping me in the
face like hot wet noodles and I'm burning
my fingers I'm reminded of how good this is
DIY colored hair conditioner if you
have brightly colored hair like mine
it's generally done using semi-permanent
dyes these fade out over about seven washes
and they don't damage hair so you can
change your hair color all the time and
it's quite fun the problem is it washes
out and when it's really faded it tends
to look a bit bad so you have to go get it
re-dyed a lot or dye it yourself at home
I started off dyeing it myself at home
every second weekend it would take a
couple of hours but I got sick of that then
I realized that you could buy colored hair
conditioners that deposit a bit of dye on
your hair every time you wash it and then
after using those for a bit I realized
in this like year of realizing stuff I
could just make my own in any color I
wanted with a conditioner that I liked
you just mix the semi-permanent dye into the hair
conditioner now this isn't entirely risk-free
because when you make your own there is a chance
that you'll mess up the preservative system and
end up with mold growing in your product
it is relatively low risk because it is a
wash off product and it's a hair product
that doesn't stay on your skin for long
but I would still recommend not mixing up too
much at a time I only mix up about enough for
a week and I make it a bit darker than I
need and I mix it in with my regular hair
conditioner in the shower right before
using it although to be honest that's
usually because I'm bad at mixing the right
amounts together so there is an upside there
having this also means I can wash
my hair every day which is what my
scalp likes without worrying about
the color ever fading too quickly
use conditioner as a hair mask you probably don't
need a separate hair mask hair masks usually have
the same core ingredients as a conditioner
but the main difference is they're usually
thicker so they stay on your hair more easily
so if you have a conditioner that works well
for you you can use it as a mask it probably
won't stay as well on your hair in the shower
though because of all that extra water you can try
wrapping your hair up in cling wrap or a plastic
shower cap like a little dumpling to keep it all
together and then clip it with a crocodile clip
I swear I am not being paid by big crocodile clip
silk pillowcase I didn't really believe in
silk pillowcases at first I thought they
were a bit of a gimmick and people just liked
them because they felt nice but I've actually
found that since I started using them I
could really tell when I didn't use one
with the silk my hair doesn't end up quite as
crunchy when I wake up compared to cotton or
linen I think that maybe I wiggle my head around a
bit when I sleep and my hair gets rubbed into the
pillow and then when the pillowcase is a bit more
frictiony then it tends to put kinks in my hair
these kinks make my hair feel crunchy and
they don't really go away until I wash my
hair it tends to be worse when I
go to sleep with damp hair and it
still does this if my hair ends up stuck
behind my back against my regular sheets
I also really like using silk scrunchies
it means the hair can slide around a bit
so the hair strands don't pull as much
on my scalp and make it sore these are
also really good for sleeping in I have to
sleep with my hair in a ponytail otherwise
it starts spreading and trying to colonize
my partner's side of the bed it's a problem
watch out for MI and MCI these are pretty common
allergens these days about 1.5% of people are
allergic to them a lot of people don't know about
them and they're actually kind of hard to avoid
I am personally allergic to them they give
me a really itchy and irritated scalp with
bumps and pimples and annoyingly they
are actually super common in shampoos
most anti-dandruff shampoos I looked at
actually had them so if you feel like your
scalp gets really grumpy with particular
products it might be worth checking for
these and seeing what happens when
you stop using products with them
this family of preservatives is also in a
lot of laundry detergents so if I use the
wrong one I get super itchy when I put on my
clothes and it always takes me a couple hours
before I remember I have an allergy so that
would be another hint and of course you can
go to a dermatologist to confirm or do
more testing if it actually isn't this
I hope these hacks were useful let me know
if you've tried any of these before or if
there's any hacks I missed don't forget to
like subscribe hit the nerdification bell
you can also see me on tiktok
and Instagram more videos are
popping up around me if you want to nerd out more